I'll see Gordon Brown's welcome my name
is Pam why do we [ __ ] up my intro it's
not that hard - feedback welcome to
create a fire legend of the brofist it's
my own game I may be a little biased but
it's clearly the best game of all time
now we beat all the level on hard as you
can see we have all the barrels and we
have two more nail levels to check out
left is a little harder but shorter no
penis joke intended and let's play ass I
think mark is better on this one cuz he
has a shield let's just use the shield
right away yet though that [ __ ]
worked out great didn't it ignore that
look at Liz use a shield which will
protect us from the next attack yes here
we go God mark a plan
come our camo man BAM jump like a bus so
this but this level is so hard because
you have to keep moving so fast oh god I
got to go faster faster harder better
faster stronger there's an unlock there
but I can't [ __ ] you mammoth doc you
barrels in the ass yes yes whoa Gangnam
style markiplier okay yes that is a fast
level it is indeed yes here's the level
we've all been waiting for Shannon what
are you doing here yeah what are you
doing that Shannon Shannon voice is just
the best shattered is an old friend of
mine oh they have no arms all right we
better help Shannon I think shot
I think sadness into bondage why are you
so slippery there we go okay so in this
level we have to keep saving the
Shannons it's kind of like the say a
first level if you remember here's the
secret
Oh God Oh God
take it first protect me Edgar Birds
aah didn't work yes son of a [ __ ] in
here how do I get up here i play this
level like more than any but I still
feel like I don't know how to play I'm
sorry Braz I'm trying I'm really trying
a switch I got it the heart of this pit
damn it
got it got it awesome another secret
let's find it there's just so much [ __ ]
going on in these levels I have a got
more hearts oh god where's the next
genin Shannon I'm coming me now where I
got you you sexy Illuminati really that
[ __ ] Illuminati god damn it pretty
pies running away from the Illuminati no
big deal just got a cool light
screenshot there too so sick of the
penguins come on
for my breast this is so this is legit
getting really [ __ ] hard there we go
all right one more Shannon the [ __ ] are
you doing there Shannon never guys we go
mommy yeah you're welcome Shannon what
are you doing cinnamon toast can I'm
gonna quest to stop those damn barrels
well you need to get up here fast I saw
snow barrel coming this way
stephannie bucket it's hard to breathe
in here all right I forgot I had you
with hahahaha actually perfect timing
Stefano I'm stuck down here I need your
guidance I got an idea
so sex ain't attached me to the road in
bear witness to my power
haha
my face so Jesus Christ safar no good
old friend always helping me out this is
all beautiful the game is the pixel is
so pretty
mm gosh and there we go
whoa I have a lot of Brook lines I
wonder how that happened I did not cheat
at all it's my game I can cheat if I'm
watching okay let's move on so this is
it'll be another boss level um we
actually have the power of the brofist
now I just want to show off the
abilities all right I may be cheating a
lobby so Ken is with me in this cave
we're gonna kill this damn thing what's
the snowman doing here Ken I don't know
but you're a sexy [ __ ] this is
obviously a barrel in disguise
obviously you sure about that how do %
Ken
hahaha my disguise works perfectly it
really did it it really did it haha the
Barrow King will be happy if you finally
get these planks on you and your
legendary power of the brofist a railing
won't get away with this I'll save my
fans you'll see
my bear head gives a beefed up smelling
senses your bear hat does that okay you
find him for you
he's very headed so cute okay here's
another boss battle uh Ken keeps like
digging up the guys such an [ __ ] but
do you know he's good but he always
sticks up like the wrong [ __ ] you'll see
in a second there we go
ah come on Ken what are those Mamet's
doing there
bam bam now let's go in terribly dr.
crab and need your assistance
oh I want to get [ __ ] it wasn't
productive crab right there okay Bri guy
this must be it
gavin barrows [ __ ] your barrels are you
kidding mate my ass to die for that damn
you man this bus is a lot harder on hard
god damn it no look at me you dead what
the [ __ ] can shove this none sad not my
ass please one more head not meteors
oh you're kidding me no [ __ ] this bus is
hard okay
I upgraded so I have more hearts because
I obviously had to do that I'm an idiot
for not doing it sooner but we should be
able to beat that son of a [ __ ] I hate
hem there we go Edgar parts activate the
power of Edgar parts the most deadliest
substance this world has ever known
come on come on goddamn it this [ __ ]
part again [ __ ] no they blocked each
other out no [ __ ] crap I need you my
buddy come on come on Michael Michael
Michael Michael walk away head up no I
didn't have enough time no no - or
something can you [ __ ] no no
no no there we go there we go
BAM one more hit for us okay one and
more [ __ ] head ah do something can't
jump stand there
I got nothing meteor rain again more
really oh [ __ ] that was [ __ ] evil GS
[ __ ] please more are you kidding me this
is ridiculous daga class damn this
blogger
damn this vlogger a slash gamer you have
no choice but to hire him who can hand
me this he won't fail me like you did
the story is very intricate and many
layers there were barrels going in and
out of this cave
ah thanks captain talking about a
prisoner that captured and there's no
time to lose
all right we're going see yeah yeah no
one follows you from here well thank you
thanks Ken
yeah [ __ ] little at work look how hard
I fail it that was really [ __ ] hard
on her
I can imagine anyone beating that on bro
if you beat that on bro you truly are a
promo okay so now we can unlock in of
course we're gonna unlock in he's the
bomb and what special ability does he
have bare head fusion well let's try
that [ __ ] out that's you bless you Paige
thank you so ken gets his little Corgi
Jackie and and Betty it's so cute and
his visual ability bear mode you can't
touch this [ __ ] yeah borrowed ah shut it
hit me god dammit the bats in this
[ __ ] game are the [ __ ] worst thing
this town has ever known secret secret
occurred damn it
see I hate tea and tea barrel soon
there's so much hate in this game I'm
sorry this is you can't jump on them
it's so annoying
you can't touch this
we play this far on the live stream we
did for the game and holy [ __ ] if we
could not beat this level Oh
choppy patch cool I love the patches of
the game it's so cool
let's get make sure to get all the
Brooklands Africa even though we have
plenty of bro codes you can never have
enough bro codes haters gonna hate bro
codes kind of bro
oh I miss ya thanks mr. chair you're the
best oh my god there's just so much [ __ ]
going on in these games I don't I don't
I genuinely don't know how to commentate
over it yes 100% there we go bro flag
max points max hearts I mean I've got
more bats get on the level damn your
bats bear mode what's your [ __ ] are you
gonna do [ __ ] that's right so cute no
there was no patch dammit alright
[ __ ] your sanic rails [ __ ] your bats
[ __ ] you everything come on I don't want
to kill Ken's dogs I look like an idiot
there we go
Oh God did we have another fangirl
that's what happens if you meet me in
real life do you really want to meet me
in real life oh god damn it I thought I
could hide there so by the end of this
cave oh there's a secret here what is it
Apache yes [ __ ] yes it's so satisfying
oh my god by the end of this level we'll
find another youtuber but here could it
be there's another patch down there but
[ __ ] it
I remember when I played this game the
first this level I just could not be
dead and the developers were watching me
and it was so awkward I just could it
was just way too hard all right well
that went pretty well let's unlock a
jack I think everyone wants to see him
probably uh since we have marks ability
we might as well do him he has a
mustache one it's pretty cool oh god the
bats here oh my god don't look at this
this does not appear until later okay
cool
Hey hey boss we've contained him sure
ezel leaders perfect this should learn
PewDiePie into our trap
take it done for now
and we'll get the promotion yeah remove
hey he's already here I feel like this
is start of like a weird fan fiction
with markiplier me and Jack
you know
mark will save him
Hey except again are you alright yeah
thanks for the rescue
let me help you why I and I will guide
you through this place awesome awesome
also overheard the barrel is talking
about their bases location this is
something around Africa
alright I'll head there next but first
let's get out of this place
all right so now little jacksepticeye
will follow us and his eye blows [ __ ] up
but we're gonna have to end that episode
there because we're running out of time
ooh are we getting to the end no we're
not there's such [ __ ] ton of levels but
I'm having so much fun playing this game
with your Bros thank you so much for
watching check out the game if you
haven't already you must do it it will
change your life
post your I score if you can beat mine
and as always stay awesome
you